in the city of Los Angeles it is all
about our hot dog this is our future
welcome to Los Angeles
where's town Nelly
like it
allow me to reintroduce myself I wanna
be a star
I'm ready for my close-up
my first movie is studio heading I want
you to stone
yes this is Sunset Boulevard Los Angeles
California
remember us
Harry Harry watch out la its major
gridlock out there this morning
make holdups on all the freeways to
service Street what are you doing to the
street we're fixing and what the hell's
it look like Laurel has places to pass I
can't get around this person until
Ventura Rolla what about you gotta stop
me dancin when I get a real gig I'll
give you a call
how's that
I read about this guy gets on the MTA
here
versus everything out in the eyes and
they forgotten what a star looks like
I woke up there again something's going
on across the street I can't see the
klieg lighter in my eye
hey Jake it's Chinatown oh there's some
money and you don't even know
Plus save money
I just want to tell you all how happy I
am Susan - you're making a picture
thank you very much Carol I'll coming
back